had another question someone wanted to
know is it okay to do fasting and Kate
hell if I'm on heart medications now the
first thing I want to say is everything
that I talk about is not meant to
substitute for your medical care check
with your doctor before taking this
advice this is mainly meant to be used
for more research with you and your
medical doctor that being said there's
some real interesting points about this
topic most people they're on heart
medication are either on a statin to
drive down the cholesterol and the LDL
they're on high blood pressure meds
diuretics also anti-clotting like
warfarin in an aspirin okay and there's
a lot of other medications as well so
let's first start out with cholesterol
medications with what a keto diet
interfere with cholesterol medications
well the big question is what causes
high cholesterol what causes high LDL
it's high insulin hyperinsulinemia
it's too much instant on the blood and
that's why diabetics have high
cholesterol and high LDL because they
have a lot of insulin in their blood in
the first stages of diabetes type 1
until it goes down then they have to
then take insulin okay so fasting and
keto will lower the insulin and also
help lower cholesterol and especially
LDL okay high blood pressure well first
of all what causes high blood pressure
will cause a stiffening of the arteries
you guessed it high levels of insulin
and fasting and keto can help reduce
this and help the flexibility of those
arteries now it also mentioned to add
potassium because potassium deficiencies
alone can cause high blood pressure and
if anyone disagrees with you
ask them what diet you should be on a
high carbohydrate diet you want to add
more carbs to raise more insulin it's
just going to actually spike your blood
pressure more and then the idea of
reducing salt is fine but you need to
also increase your potassium because
potassium is sodium work together and
the more ratio of
to sodium that you have the better the
blood pressure
the problem with diuretics is it pulls
out potassium so it creates a potassium
deficiency making the sodium actually
more and when you have low potassium you
actually increase insulin resistance and
it causes more insulin so not a good
combination okay then you have
anti-clotting what causes a clot in the
first place high insulin so by doing
fasting and in keto lowering your carbs
you can reduce the risk of stroke and
cardiovascular accidents now if you're
on warfarin you can't do leafy greens so
you're gonna have to watch the video
below and make mental note of all the
vegetables that you can have that are
low in vitamin k1 now the other an
interesting point about the heart that
is different than skeletal muscle is
this the heart muscle does not have a
glycogen reserve it doesn't store sugar
like muscle tissue the heart muscle
prefers to run on ketones and fatty
acids in fact 85% of the fuel for the
heart is fatty acids so it loves fat why
wouldn't you want to do a keto diet now
there's another interesting study that
talks about high insulin
hyperinsulinemia as a predictor for
major adverse cardiovascular events so
the healthy version of keto and
interment fasting are especially
beneficial to the heart hopefully the
eventual goal is to wean yourself off
this with the help of your doctors but
you need a long-term plan to get at the
root of this problem which is this right
here and by the way this is behind the
metabolic syndrome which basically
describes a high cholesterol high blood
pressure diabetes and belly fat anyway
thanks for watching and I will see you
in the next video if you're liking this
content please subscribe now and I will
actually keep you updated on future
videos